Good morning.
Good morning, sir. Morning. Morning, sir.
Morning. Good ones.
Good morning, sir. Good morning. Good morning.
Good morning, sir. Good morning. Good.
So I guess we can start now.
Um, uh, okay. Has also joined.
Good morning, sir.
So Neil, how do we go?
Uh, yes, sir. So in the last class we have, uh, started
with R and n, and, uh, we had just made clear
with the sequential data why r
and n needs required only that much point.
Now we can go with RN architecture a little bit in depth.
So first up we can, uh, you can explain,
and then I will take them again to some examples and on.
So we'll, uh, today discuss about only this RN
and part, uh, not the lstm. And, you know,
Uh, yes, sir, yes.
Only rn. Yes.
Okay. Let me share this. Yes,
Some network issues slightly just sharing,
speaking some time.
Is my screen shared?
No, sir. No, sir. I, I'm going to share this.
Um, Sunni just, uh, uh, continue
for five minutes.
I will re reboot the system and join.
Okay, sir. Thanks. Yeah, until that point,
you can just discuss few points.
Yeah.
Okay, sir. My,
okay.
So, uh, as a quick recap, what we did in the, uh,
last class, I will just,
So in the last class, uh, uh, first of all,
we understood, uh, a clear difference, uh, that
what is the sequential data?
How or how is the nature of the sequential data
and how it is different from non-sequential data?
So in the case of non-sequential data, maybe the order,
the sequence doesn't matter much, right?
But at the sequential data,
unless you don't have that sequence
or context preserved, it'll be very difficult for the model,
the neural network model, which you're trying to build
to understand that context
and then to give you the output accordingly.
And we have seen that the a NN struggles with, with that,
uh, uh, in, in maintaining those sequence, A
and N also has, uh, uh, some more problems
while processing the sequential data.
And the first problem, what we discussed,
that if your sequential data like text, uh, uh,
text, which is in the variable length in size,
because once you have a corpus,
you will never have all the sentences
of equal length, right?
So the every sentence will be of, uh, uh,
or every sentence, uh, will be of slightly different length.
There is a possibility, high possibility of that, right?
Some sentences might be having the same length also,
but then overall, if you see the sentences will be
of different, different length.
But the requirement from the a n is
that you should have always fixed number of inputs,
which you have to feed to the a NN.
But my number of words are different in each sequence.
No, that's where there is a mismatch.
So model side requirement is you always feed me the fixed
number of tokens or words,
but when we see our sentence, the fixed number of words,
we can't be, sometimes there is only three words here.
Sometimes there might be four words here.
Sometimes there might be five words here.
That means that data structure is different,
model requirement is different,
and that's where there is a mismatch, okay?
So what we, what we talked, we can do,
we can fix this problem, okay?
If we, if at all, we try to use the ENN
and we want to fix this problem,
we can use this zero padding approach.
We can just see the maximum length
of a sentence in our whole corpus,
and then we can start padding zeros.
Okay? So every sentence will be of the equal length,
having some zeros added at the last,
and then we can feed all the sentences in
a similar way, right?
But this, this approach has its own problem.
The problem is, first of all, in this case, the number
of inputs will be in will increase massively.
Hence, computation will also increase.
Parameters will also increase.
Because if you have here 15 inputs, then 15 into three,
only 45 parameters are required.
If you will have a hundred inputs,
then maybe a hundred into three,
300 inputs would be required.
And we are just adding zeros
to make all the sentences of equal.
And so in every, in most of the cases, what will happen,
your sentence will not be equivalent to the maximum length
of a sentence in the corpus.
And hence, you're simply adding the zeros sum
and then parameters, you are,
or computation, first of all, increase.
And the parameters also, it has to be updated in
with the back position and all.
So these are the, these are all the issues.
What you can see what happens when you process the variable
length input with the ENN one more problem, what we talked,
if you can remember now, suppose somehow you manage it
parameters, computer resources
and everything, it is possible that at the test time,
a new sentence will come whose length will be even more than
what you had fixed at the training time here, okay?
And that time, again, that network will fail.
And there is always possibility of getting a new,
new sentence of having the more, more, uh, uh, length,
more number of words, right?
So this was another problem.
And this problem was, uh, we already talked that A and n,
because it's process, all the words parallelly right?
In the network, hence, it doesn't preserve the context.
At the same time it is processing. We are in LLM class.
So these, these nodes
or these neurons receives all these informations
equally, okay?
And hence, they don't able
to differentiate whether R has come first V has come later,
or whatever it is, whatever that, that sequence information,
it is not able to because everything we are
processing once, right?
So this is another problem, what we talked about in the,
in the case of ENN.
So overall, we talked like fixed input size, uh, um,
uh, of, uh, this is the nature of the feed
for one neural network, always expect the fixed input size.
Then it cannot handle the text, which is a sequential
variable length sequences, loss of order information.
Suppose we start feeding the text data
to the a NN order.
We are losing inefficient computation
and poor generalization, all these things we talked about.
And hence, we, we require a network, a neural network,
which can fix these problem,
which can address these problem.
What is the problem means a new neural network should handle
the variable length inputs.
It also preserve the order information.
And because your inputs, uh, the, the words in a sequence
will be, uh, handled, uh, eh, we want,
because, uh, we want the context to be preserved, right?
So somehow we want also the parameter, which is going,
or, uh, through these words,
while processing should also be shared so that
that information will go to the neuron, right?
That, okay, this, this, uh, uh,
somehow those information will go to the neuron
that this words and all I have already seen, right?
And it'll reduce the parameters
overall computations as well.
So share parameter across time
and maintain memory of the past input.
So all these are the requirement which this recurrent
network is going to address.
And at last we said this is the, this is the plan,
what we have for this RNN to, uh, approach.
So first we'll start with a simple RNN today,
and then we'll talk about the back replication a little bit.
Then we'll jump into the S-T-M-G-R-U, then we'll go
to the deep RNN and bidirectional.
So this is what we covered.
I, sir has also covered the same thing,
and I had also given you some, uh,
with the examples, the same perspective.
Maybe if you have any questions still that you can ask.
And then we'll go to the next.
Sir, one question sharing across the parameters, is it
to only the weight, sir?
Shared? Wait, wait. Yeah.
We'll, we'll show that the
architecture, it'll be more clear.
What does it mean? Yeah, I'm sharing my screen.
Yes. See that kindly confirm.
Otherwise, you may have to share. Yes, sir. I'll just
Confirm you.
Is it coming? My No,
No, no, no, sir. No,
sir. I'll share.
And then you come here, there is some issue here.
Yeah, I just share Second. Second.
Any other Question from anyone?
Yeah,
Yeah, Yeah.
Uh, so we have covered till here. Go down, go down, go down.
Up to this point, yes, you can.
You can go for the screen more.
Yes.
Any, any questions from any of you
see the sequence modeling as, uh, Dr.
Sunil was mentioning, even though, see, both
of us are trying to repeat,
but there's a very, very crucial link.
How essentially we capture the sequence knowledge, um,
in a neural network is a very, very important concept
that we have to get hold onto.
Um, otherwise, uh, the conventional, um,
multi-layer perception is essentially
to capture a snapshot like thing.
The sequence has no meaning there.
So that is where, uh, the whole thing, uh,
the current neur network, uh,
I think came into picture in the last session.
Also, we explained about pictorially.
Uh, an RA is represented like this in the literature,
so you should not be confused by no, there are only one
or two, three neurons
or something just
as a compact representation they are mentioning.
And second thing is, um, on this, uh, uh, hedge node,
which is representing all the hidden layers,
the sequence knowledge is captured in the hidden layers,
and then pass it on from one position
to the next position in the sequence,
or one timing
instant to the next.
That is what it indicates.
Actually, we may not study as a part of this, uh,
deep learning, but, um, cd, just like all these,
uh, neural network architectures
that we are studying are all feed forward
neural network architectures.
That means, say the data flows from
the input layer to the output layer.
And recurrent neural network is also a feed
forward neural network.
Okay? So in, in that condition, um, that mr,
a signal flow happens from input layer output,
then we are showing an arrow which is coming back.
It should not be confused
with the feedback neural network in the feedback neural
network, the signal flow happens in the, uh,
backward direction.
Here, there is nothing. It's still a field
forward architecture.
This, this loop is just to indicate
that the weight parameters of the run layers,
that knowledge is passed from one
position to the next position.
That's all it means. Okay, next slide.
Uh, so yeah,
so, uh, now just, uh, uh, for your information,
the recurrent neural network concept were proposed way back
in 1986 by, um,
again, know a contemporary of, uh,
or Jeffrey intern and all those things.
Al Hart, his name is Al Har, uh, he proposed,
he and his team proposed
and neur network architecture, they called it
as a current neural networks for
modeling the sequence information.
So essentially, they mentioned them
as a family of neural networks meant
for processing the sequential data.
And again, no, this is also motivated from
the CNN architecture, uh, which we studied earlier,
which was meant for processing a grid of values.
The X will be a, typically when they propose it
to the two dimensional data,
and a two dimensional data is divided into smaller blocks,
and a very small block is processed parallelly
to model the information
because the neighborhood carries, uh, um, uh, information,
which will help, uh, to model knowledge about a particular
focus point there in the grid.
Okay? In the same way, uh,
in the recurrent neur network, they visualize
the recurrent neur network as a neural network
that is specialized for processing a sequence of values.
For example, XF one, XF two of three, et cetera, X of two.
This, the indices in the bracket represent
the position in the sequence or the order in the sequence.
And, um, suppose if I take, uh,
a speech recognition task, the input sequence can be
a sequence of feature vectors, say XF one,
XF two, et cetera.
Uh, means I have a recorded speed signal
and I'm processing them to extract the feature vectors
and the feature extracted for each frame of data.
Frame one is XF one, feature vector.
Frame two is XF two feature vector,
and frame three is XF three and so on.
And whereas the output, uh, can be a text, uh,
sequence of text words, whatever.
Now, for example, um, um, if I say,
um, assume that, uh,
I record a speech signal for the phrase
recurrent neural network is the, uh, sequence
of words in the text format.
It has only three words. Recurrent neural network.
That is why one Y two, Y three, whereas the speech recorded
for this world recurrent neur network, when we extract it
as features, it represents x of one, x of two, x of three,
maybe some hundred feature vectors are there.
X of one, two x of hundred will be there.
That needs to be converted into Y one, Y two, Y three,
where Y one is recurrent, Y two is neural,
and Y three is, uh, um, network as a neural network.
So that is nothing
but this, no, that is an example of, uh, um,
model training and test training purpose
of the neural network.
The point I wanted to emphasize is there is no relation
between the time indices
or sequence position indices of the input and the output.
In this case, as I was telling you, when I take,
when I record this P signal for a grand neural network
and convert them to sequence of feature vectors,
it can be having say, 50 feature vectors.
Then first feature vector is X of one.
Second feature vector is x of two,
and so on X of 50, whereas the output when it is decoded,
there are only three positions.
YF one is recurrent, YF two is neural,
and YF three is network.
That's all I need to convert the input sequence.
50 feature vectors into three words in the output.
Similarly suppose, um,
the same recurrent neural network I generate next,
I generate the speech for the same sequence of three words.
Next time it can be a, it can be a four,
it can have 47 feature vectors, then x
of X one, x two, et cetera, X 48,
whereas the output is still remains at Y one, Y two,
Y three, and so on.
So that is, that means the input sequence changes in length
and, uh, the output sequence can be fixed
or it can also change in length.
But at this point of time, I just want to say that
we should not, uh, uh, no, um,
have a view that, um, the
sequence input and output sequence will have same length
input and output sequence length can be different
in each example for training
and each example for test,
because I'm, I'm slightly worried in this slide,
I have mentioned it as X one, x two X extend,
and Y one, Y 2 8 10, we should not mistake that.
No, whether there are 10 value in the sequence
and 10 will be map into 10 values in the output.
Why, you know, while writing, we might have done that,
but there is no relation between the length
of the sequence in the input and the output.
Okay, next slide.
So I think, uh, I, I also emphasize it many times, uh,
that Sunil was also mentioning.
Now the key idea, the key idea
in moving from this multi-layer percept arm
or whatever network that we have studied so far
to recurrent neur network is sharing parameters across
different parts of the model,
sharing parameters across different parts of the model.
Um, essentially, um, for example,
the different parts
of the model means I will take the same example.
I recorded the speech signal for the sequence of words,
a phrase that's a network.
I take the first feature vector XF one, using that, say
I compute some weight parameters, okay?
And, uh, then I move to the next position, XF two.
XF two is the input value I'm getting
and, uh, while processing XF two
to update the weight parameters.
And I not only consider the information given by XF two,
I will also consider the information that was present, uh,
in frame X one, but I don't connect it directly to the X two
or the X two position from X one.
I have captured whatever information available in X one in
the form of the weights in the hidden layers,
and the weights in the hidden layers from the previous
timestamp position.
X one, I call it as H one, that weights from
that position are used along with the weights associated
with X two to update the weights
for this position of the hidden layers.
So that is what is the sharing parameters
across different parts of product.
We'll see that when you go
to the next pictorial representation.
So essentially, uh,
it involves sharing parameters across different hidden
layers as opposed to independent weights.
In the case of multi-layer perceptor, so this,
maybe you have to pause for a while
and think over, um, if, if I visualize, um,
a multilayer percept run,
every link weight is unique.
There is no, uh, sharing of that value with any other link.
So I have a new feedforward network structure,
a multilayer ance structure.
Every link is given one weight parameter
and, um, that will remain unique.
There is no sharing across in another link
or another layer or something.
So that is the unique characteristics
of multi-layer perception.
Whereas in case of recurrent network, we share
that parameters why we share that parameters
that essentially is expected to model the sequence knowledge
that Mr say what was present in the, uh,
in the previous position,
that knowledge is, um, carried
by the weights in the layer parameters.
Now I will add that to the knowledge
that is being exhibited by the current position
and then update this one.
So that means to say, as I go on sharing, maybe
saying other ways, assume that, uh,
in a multilayer perception, I have 48 feature vectors,
I apply first feature vector and update the weights,
and, um, I apply second feature vector,
but need not be X two randomly anyone out of that four eight
and update the weights.
Update the weights means what happens is, um,
there is no provision in the hidden layer structure,
other neural network structure that you,
you org you join the information available
by both the weights or something,
you just update the weights.
That is to say, um, uh,
there's no almost like a replacement of the weights,
whereas here, it's like a fractional update like thing will
happen, uh, as I move from one
position to the other position.
Okay? Then, um,
but why this sharing of parameters, um, or
otherwise, no, I would've just captured the sequence
knowledge in each position and kept it separately.
But why the sharing of thing happens, mainly
because the sequence lens are different from one example
to the other example, I will not be able to, you know, uh,
handle that variable sequence length if I don't have this
sharing of parameters.
It is almost like, you know, folding unfolding, for example,
on an average, the number of feature vectors are 45
some in one example is 45.
Another example, 41, another example, 47.
So that what will happen around that 41 case when it has 41,
another case around 48, we don't know how to deal with
that variable, whereas the sharing is there.
I just go on know, uh, the, just go on updating.
That is another element for updating the weight.
That's how it happens. So the other
other thing is,
Is, um, important
because, uh, positions in the sequence,
so when you are having a compressional expansion,
the same piece of information
can happen at multiple culture.
Um, that's what, no, finally, it, uh,
results in an optimizer structure compared to MLP.
Uh, so some sort
of recurring recurrence is happening, let me say the same
phenomenon is repeating and again and again,
and that's why they call as a current neural network
that Mr say the weight parameters are
updated as we move from one time position
to the other time position,
that means the sequence knowledge will
occur again and again.
And that is what we are trying to model.
And hence the call the name of the network
as recurrent neur networks works.
Next slide, Sue.
So whatever I said, uh, so far,
let me try to explain using this pictorial representation,
The left part of this diagram, if you see now
this is a typical representation of
a recurrent neural network.
So this X of T represent the input layer,
input layer at, uh, time position, TX
of T, and the corresponding predicted output vector
is y cap of T means using this input
at time position, I can predict the corresponding output at
position T, the predicted value is Y cap of T.
And the goal is you, when you are,
when you are applying an input at time t
you predict the corresponding at that time.
T by pausing this information through a,
a cell called recurrent cell,
recurrent cell is nothing, but is the bunch
of all the hidden layers present
in the recurrent neural network.
Okay? Now, if you see
to predict this output, yt, you need, for example,
you're applying the input.
If you see this connection, uh,
roll called rolling connection of ht, you have,
what it indicates is when it is feeding back here,
which essentially this is HT, means, this is assumed
to be HT minus one.
This assumed to be hd, this position is assumed to
the left side where the RO is entering.
That is a previous sequence position, okay?
Now, what will happen is you see the equation.
Now the, the recurrent
sequence value that is a hidden recurrent cell
sequence knowledge, and we call this as recurrent cell,
and that cell is nothing but the whole bunch of,
all the layer that are present, okay?
That, uh, uh, recurrent cell, the current, uh,
state, our value of the recurrent cell is HFT
is computed using the current input XFT
and the previous state of the recurrent cell, HFT minus one,
this is the old state.
HFT minus is the old state of the recurrent neural network,
and the current input vector is X of T.
And
the, uh, current, the recurrence cell is computed as a fund
of both the current input as well
as the previous state of the recurrence cell.
And what is that function?
Function is given by a set of weight values.
W which is there is a weight associated with the old state
of the network and a weight associated
with the current bonding input vector.
And that is, uh, multiplied with these values.
And, uh, nonlinear processing happens to give you the
current cell state, current cell state,
we need to appreciate what I explained here.
If you have any doubt, let me know.
So here we are, we are seeing the old state, right? Um,
Ava current, please, can you please repeat Akan
Here we are just sharing weight
or we are also using the old state
of the function as well as,
Okay, uh, that's a very good question.
So see here, uh,
we are using the old state value
that is this ro is there no left side RO
that is hf T minus one old state.
And the old state value is nothing
but the weight values, which are there at that till
that point, okay?
Okay. And similarly, the current state xft is represented
through a, in this link, xft entering into the recurrent,
uh, that is given by a weight metrics,
say WXX
and the weight value for the previous S-A-W-H-H HT
or HH minus one, we'll see the XH two X or something
and the weight parameters, that was their weight values
of the recurrence cells that were there
till the previous incident of time.
That is given by this weight value WHFS.
And that H of T minus that is nothing
but this H of T minus one.
Oh, sir, thank you Sir. Ish. Yes, sir.
Sir, when we are sharing the parameter in the previous
slide, it was mentioned that, uh,
it also identifies the variable length, sir.
So how sharing the parameter identifies the length
of variable length of the words, sir, of the sentences.
It'll not identify the very variable length.
I don't know whether I set
that point down there in the slide.
I'm not sure, but go to the previous slide.
Uh, it'll not need not identify the variable
Variables in the third point.
Variable sequence length sharing parameter
helps to generalize it.
Variable sequence lens, variable sequence,
I means the sequence lens, uh, uh, sequence lens will be of,
uh, sequences will be of different length,
and, uh, it should be able to handle
that without worrying about no, whatever the length
of the sequence that is the meaning of that.
I don't recognize the sequence lens,
Okay? That
that is very, no.
Uh, you just go to the, uh, next slide.
Uh, see this recurrent cell, no.
If you see, uh, this looping
that is available here, it doesn't matter.
For example, if, uh, I was telling
that if there is a 45 lens, normal length is 45,
this structure is used 45 times.
Alternatively, if the next example,
the sequence length is 41, this loop is run 41 times.
Yes sir. Another case, it is 49, it'll be run 49 times.
I don't have to bother as long as I re
until I reach the last position in the sequence,
I can go on reusing that, uh, structure.
Yes. So it, that means that each hidden layer,
we will have one, uh, neuron, uh, neural, uh,
recurring cell in each of the hidden layers.
Apart from hidden neuron cell. No,
The whole, the whole recurrent neural network is the
entire hidden layer structure.
The entire hidden layer structure
is recorded as recurrent cell. Okay?
Yes. Thank you.
So only let me, let me say like this.
Um, maybe, uh, just to further impress on,
uh, suppose if, if I have to write,
um, this equation, um,
of multi-layer perception network, okay,
that could have been this HT minus one
would not have been there.
Only FFW
of XFT would've been there,
No, uh, this HT minus one is specifically preserving the
sequence knowledge sequence.
Yes. And what otherwise, uh, what is the equation for
multilayer receptor?
HFT is got the FW of xft X. Yes.
Which is, anyway, you don't have to preserve
that goes to the output.
No. And try to take that.
Okay, we'll go to the next, uh,
yeah, Sunil.
Yeah. So slightly expanding that,
uh, you'll see how it is happening here.
Uh, please remember the previous equation,
F of W, that F is nothing
but 10 hyperbolic function.
And the W is given like this
HF minus one Neil multiplied by a weight matrix, WHH
and A weight material WXH.
So, um, symbolically also it represents, uh,
uh, this one that H two H is nothing
but the weight values at the previous instant of position
carried to the weight values at the current instant
of position, the WHH means they kept these weight metrics
capture the sequence knowledge.
WXH means the, the
weight values due to the input vector X to the hidden cell
or the recurrent cell, the WXH.
Okay? And now what come through the cell,
I use the sequence HT minus one input
multiplied by the reference weight weight vector.
And this is nothing about activation value of the current,
possibly the output function done hyper body
to get the recurrent cell output at current instant
of time ht.
Okay? I think the T at this point also
tap the upper of the position also,
and that is further pass through.
If I want to compute the output value at
that particular incident of time, there is a weight metrics
H two Y, the current recurrent value, uh,
weight metrics I'm considering
and multiplying with the, you know,
weight vector WHY, multiplied by HT
to get the corresponding output value at timet.
Now you see now, um, you have three weight metrics here,
one weight metrics, WXH sitting on the lower
RO from XT to the input of the recurrence cell.
And there is another WHHT
sitting on the left ro that is sequence knowledge
using W-X-H-W-H-H
and the correspond HT minus one
and xd I compute the current state value H of T
and the current state value H of T will be passed on to the,
uh, this w uh,
HH updated WHH will be pass on
to the next sequence position.
Um, and, uh, the HD value is computed that is used
for computing the corresponding output position at this
point, I think this is another, the previous one
and this current one, this is how the computation happens
at each position.
So this is slide as soon, the previous slide
and uh, see now I'm expanding the generic equation.
How it is there. We essentially, first thing is
how do I compute the, uh,
the recurrent cell output at time T is given
by this equation?
Then how do I compare the output at this current time
is another equation.
And we are expanding, you know,
there is a weight metrics here, W-X-H-W-H-H
and then WHY next slide.
And this is what is shown here.
Maybe I want you people to now compare these two slides
and spend some time in understanding
how the sequence knowledge works.
Next slide. Ah,
now, uh, you see how, uh, this,
now I don't want to show this repeated symbol.
If, if you want to actually show me how
an unfolded recurrent neural network happens,
because I mentioned it as a feed forward neural network.
This is how it happens.
Uh, in this figure, we have taken time in the starting from
time T equal to zero.
Now X zero is there, I'm applying to the recurrent cell
through a weight metrics WXH,
then, then I compute the
weight value WHH,
that is capturing the sequence knowledge,
and that is passed on to the next instant of time, x
of X one.
And before
that there is a WHH coming from the previous position.
But since I'm starting at uh, uh, um,
starting at the time, t equal to zero, that is
that initial value.
Maybe it can be a random value or something.
But once that is over next loop onwards,
there is a previous instant computed value using these two.
I compute the, um, no hidden value
state value HF T,
and that is ED through is WHY
to get the corresponding output.
Why not that means to say
for every position there is an output computer.
Let me tell. In the simplified value at time T equal
to zero, I will predict the corresponding output YY zero
cap, then at time T equal to one.
I predict the output at that point Y cap one,
similarly time T equal to two, I predict the, uh,
output Y cap two.
And so on a time T small TI predict
that final output Y cap T, that is that.
Now what is that we have to see is when a time T equal
to one while predicting Y cap one,
I not only use the current current input XF
and XF one, I will also improve,
use the knowledge from the previous time instant T equal
to zero through this link, which is pass on
that is W-H-H-W-H-H
and the HT minus one value that is coming here
that will be used for computing the output.
Okay? Rab, the, this will,
did this answer your Yes, sir.
Yeah, yeah, thank you. HHT minus one is coming
here along with this WHH.
Okay, so this is how, uh, this, this is the difference.
I know in MLP there is this link is missing in
MLP, this link is missing.
That is how, and for example,
I can compute the error in prediction separately,
locally at each test timestamp position, L zero, L one,
L two, L three,
and then you can accumulate all of them
to get the total layer in prediction.
That is what it is. Capital L is, uh, represented here.
Actually, when you, when you actually write
expanded way, you want to write an RNN diagram.
It goes like this way, this, all this, uh,
see the, the, the same, uh,
a very, very important point.
See when I'm saying sharing parameters across the time
position, you see the position X zero X one,
x two XT are coming, whereas you see the weight parameters,
the same weight parameters are shared.
It is always W-H-H-W-X-W-H-Y.
That means to say the same set
of y parameters are, are shared.
That's why it's called the sharing of parameters. Okay?
So that is the,
and now what happens,
it doesn't matter the sequence length folding
or unfolding, this tee can be, uh, different length.
It doesn't matter for that.
If it is 41, it stops there, it'll fortify, it increases
by four times, it'll run more.
It's unfolding. Uh, 49 means it unfolds another four times.
Okay? Next slide,
Sir.
Yes, previously, Uh, sir, uh, sir, in this,
I'm not able to understand this,
WHH will be the same weight parameter.
So like initially we have this X zero will be zero also
because we are taking the initial state.
So zero is not zero x zero will be the input vector
parameter vector value time t equal to zero.
Okay? Yes, ma'am. This WC in this diagram,
uh, since it is starting position,
this WH will be there in from a previous link.
There is no previous link.
The WHH, maybe you can keep it for some, uh,
some non-zero value or something.
Sunil will show when it is showing the implementation,
maybe initially the WHH has kept some arbitrary
value, okay?
After first iteration, that gets updated. WHH, yes, yes.
So yes. So this WHH is this the output
that we are tapping from the activation function
output of the out function?
We are tapping it and we giving it to the next layer.
Yes, yes. That is a updated weight.
Yes, sir. So in that case, now, if we go
for the second layer, we have this X one parameter,
then we have the two weights coming into the activation
function, and then that output of
that function again given to the third layer.
So in this case then
how the weights will be common
across the layers, there'll be different.
No. So because we are taking the input of the other layer,
then we are adding the percent weights,
and then we are tapping the output of
that activation function,
giving it across to all the layers.
So in that way, the weight will be,
there'll be some variation in the weights.
No, wonderful, wonderful.
So, um, the, the, when, what I meant
when it's called sharing of parameters, uh, rajesh, um,
it is, I am not suppose if
updated weights are there.
For example, uh, let us call this position.
One weight parameter says just for example, uh,
I put W superscript 1 1 1 in
all positions, okay?
Yes, sir. Wx, H one W hh one WHY one, okay? Yes.
Then I keep it. Then I take WXH two
WHH two WHY two for position two.
Okay? Then I'm preserving a separate copies
of the weights, okay?
Yes. Whereas what, what I'm doing is the same set
of parameters are getting updated
and going to the next position.
Okay? Understood. Understood. No, I understood, sir.
Otherwise, no, you need to keep the metrics values of,
uh, each positions,
Yes, yes, yes.
That is what is, Yes. Thank you, sir.
Thank you. Thank you. Yeah, we'll go to the next slide.
Ah, see, uh,
before I come to this, uh, previous slide, previous slide.
So see what happens now, uh, you,
you go starting from X code
to zero time t there is a signal flow happening.
See, there is something at every snapshot, if you see
every snapshot X zero X one, x two, you see it
as separate MLP connection.
There is an input applying a sequence
of done layers are there from their output gets computed.
Okay? I see that vertically.
One slide, and there can be multiple hidden layers.
They're all put into one
recurrent neural network block or a current cell.
If you see there is a know
what we call, um, signal flow happens up
to the output layer and the bap
propagation of error happens.
Then using that BAP propagation error,
you can adjust the weights of the network.
Okay? The, that is one way of adjusting the weights.
The other way of adjusting the weight is, uh, uh,
essentially, um, uh, vertically at each position,
I can adjust the weights by considering one snapshot,
the same set of weight parameters.
I can adjust by considering this horizontal movement also
from right to left.
If I see that the sequence knowledge captured,
and based on that, I can adjust the weights of the network.
Okay? If, if I take the vertical snap,
that propagation error happening at
that particular one slice, that is nothing
but the vanishing gradient problem that we discussed.
If you see no deep learning model had a vanishing gradient
problem or something that is at a given snapshot,
there can be a number of layers.
It'll data goes to the output layer and feedback happen.
The error, uh, comes down
and it can end up in becoming a vanishing gradient.
Accordingly, I may not be able
to adjust the weights of some layers.
That phenomenon is still relevant,
still relevant in each each vertical snapshot.
The vanishing gradient problem,
but, uh, X zero is relevant, X one is relevant,
X two is relevant, and XT is relevant, like
what we discussed so far.
If you see in, in general, suppose
that any person X one position,
I consider one snapshot of RNN.
Assume that there's recurrence cell as some five layers,
and then it is essentially a deep network
of five layers say,
and naturally there is a vanish ingredient problem, uh,
inherent in that snapshot of the, that we have studied.
But now the other thing is,
suppose I go on moving like this up
to time T from X sub zero, then I get the final error,
and using the error I horizontally, I come back
and adjust the weights
of all the weight parameters essentially to adjust
with reference to the sequence knowledge.
Okay? And that also as the number of unfolding increases,
there is also a vanishing gradient problem happens,
and that is, that is nothing
but bad propagation through time.
Uh, the weight parameters adjustment due
to the sequence knowledge that is happening
from right to left.
And uh, then the cons, the propagation
that we discuss about propagation of error that we discussed
so far is at any one type sequence times,
uh, sequence snapshot.
Whereas in the recurrent neural network,
we also have another concept called BAP propagation
through time where in any position, I can move back, uh,
to adjust of those
parameters to capture the knowledge
with reference to the sequence.
And that is the BAP propagation through time that we are,
and that will also complicate the vanishing gradient problem
in the recurrent neur network.
So that is one new phenomenon which is not there
so far will evolve now. Okay, next,
Sir, one second sir, please.
Yes, I have a question, sir.
I can, we, um, I mean the question is,
suppose the input was say RNN
uh, recurrent neural network.
So in this case, X zero will be recurrent X one will be, um,
neural, and uh, X two will be in network.
And um, these three inputs X zero, X one,
x two are put at the same time, sir,
or T one, T two, T three,
or at the time T zero, all the three will have,
all the three X's will have these three words.
Wonderful, wonderful. That's a very good question.
Next, uh, question. So suppose assume
that X zero X one, et cetera, XT is given to you
for training the network.
We maintain the order like this.
First I apply X zero, okay?
And do all this snapshot of X zero
to Y zero prediction, okay?
Then I get this WHH, then I take X one
and apply x one and com.
Use the updated weight value, WHH, updated weight value,
WXH and WHA and compute Y one.
Okay? So at every position I apply
only one input.
Mm-hmm. And predict the output
while predicting the output.
I will use the most recent updated weight parameters.
I if you see the same as previous, uh, question asked, no,
we are not in the weight, uh, metrics value,
WXH is a weight metrics, WHH is another weight metrics,
WHY is another weight metrics.
There is no position index given to them.
That means to say the same set
of weight parameters are recurrent,
are repeating at all position.
That's why the name recurrent neural networks, okay?
That is one part why it is called recurrent the same set
of weight parameters.
We are using a different instance of time
or sequence position.
And when I'm computing at X one,
these are inherently already updated, corresponding
to the previous position.
Okay? When I go to X two, this WHH is already updated,
corresponding to the previous position, okay?
Mm-hmm. And we apply one at a time.
I use X zero compute output.
At that point, this remaining position is not there
at when I apply X one only,
I apply X one and compute the output.
Okay? And that is how,
and that is how I come one position at a time
till the expiry of the last position in the sequence.
I come like that left to right,
Right, sir? Sir.
And, um, WXH
and WHY will only change in the normal
like we read in a NN.
It'll only change during that backdrop. Yes.
But WHH will change from X zero to X one.
Uh, I mean, it'll keep on changing in time
as we are applying those inputs.
Yes, correct. Okay.
Okay, sir. Okay.
And there thereby wise will also be generated, uh,
sequentially, like, you know, okay.
Yes, yes. No, I, I this is generic.
That's a very good, uh, observation you have pointed out.
See, at any position, when I see no,
when I'm predicting X one, I have from X one position,
I should be able to predict Y one.
Mm-hmm. So according with this WXH
and WHI will be dominated
by this vertical computing that I'm doing.
Mm-hmm. Whereas this one has to carry
that sequence knowledge.
So that is where they are changed
as you move from one sequence version to others,
maybe I think this will, I, I thank you all
for asking this question.
I think when are explaining the one work examples,
then it'll be become more, uh, no, we will get more clarity.
Okay? Uh, what I wanted to say is see
BAP propagation we studied in the multilayer perceptron.
In case of this RNN,
there is something called bap propagation through time
that also comes, which I position X zero to xt,
I go and then come back.
There is an error coming back through time.
And that is called bpro.
That is uniquely meant
for our sequence knowledge network sequence networks.
Okay? Next slide. This is what, uh, this is
what we have started study bion in feedforward model.
We have studied this very, if you recall now, no,
I apply input X get the output and error ation happens
and we are told no.
As the number of redan layer increases,
the vanishing gradient problem comes.
That is what we have been exposed to. Now next slide.
As this is what happens now in the AL network.
Okay, see this vertical, uh,
red s which this is the conventional BA
propagation we have studied.
Now we also have what is called B propagation through time.
Uh, you see no left arrow coming red darrow that, uh,
no ba propagation other happens through time.
Also, see this paper propagation conventional pap
application that we have studied in forward backward pass.
As the number of layer increases, it'll contribute
to vanishing gradient problem.
Now, at every snapshot I have a vanishing gradient problem
due to that vertical pass, conventional map propagation.
Along with that, you see there is another
complication coming here.
There is a propagation through time, which is happening,
and that will also add value
to your vanishing gradient problem.
That means say the vanishing gradient problem becomes more
aggravated in case of recurrent network compared to
what was happening in the previous case.
Okay, fine.
Next slide. Actually,
see this experiment one student did and gave me the result.
Um, you don't have to take these numbers, uh,
very seriously,
but just, uh, to give an illustration of,
um, um, sequence knowledge.
He has done it, but I'm not happy with the, uh,
numbers, what he has generated.
But at least just to, uh, indicate no the process.
Uh, for example, there is a sentiment
classification problem.
There is an IMDB data set.
Is there, which is movie reviews dataset,
standard data set is there.
So to ca, oh, there is a standard thing.
Sentiment classification is there,
and the sentiment information is, uh,
essentially sequence knowledge.
I read the review based around that.
I want to give a sentiment, positive sentiment
or negative sentiment or something.
And that is that classification task.
What he did is he considered sequence length as of 50, uh,
the see what sequence length, uh, reviews, which are
of 50 word length.
And uh, um, typically, you know,
don't worry about the time what is required.
Um, the accuracy he got by the 50
uhfor network is about 50% binary classification, positive
or negative.
Uh, he got only accuracy of 50%,
which is stands probably binary
classification, positive or negative.
That means to say the neural network is not able to
classify build a classifier,
which can do sentiment classification of
what it is expected.
Uh, mainly because whether it's positive or negative.
Suppose I have sequence lens of 50 words.
I scan through that 50 words based around that.
I develop a sentiment as a positive or negative.
But in the feed four network, there is no way I can give
that, uh, capture the sequence knowledge.
Whereas in the recurrent neur network,
the same sequence length, it gives me some
significantly higher performance
because it processes the sequence knowledge.
And uh, of course, naturally, you know,
here I'm randomly choosing
and applying, uh, this one, whereas here
I can apply in batch process, whereas in the time as I have
to apply in sequence one
after the other, that sequence,
that's why it takes more time to compute.
Uh, that is the difference between FFN
and the recurrent neur network.
Okay? Same way, if I take a hundred
sequence length this time, fit four network time
for testing remains same, whereas, uh,
in the recurrent network takes more time
because I'm processing the sequence length of some improve.
But of course, you know, this further numbers,
as you increase the sequence length, it's not improving.
I'm not really trusting these numbers.
Third and fourth row only, I just want to say for through,
if you take, um, uh, since recurrent neur network is able
to capture the sequence length, uh,
it is able to do a better classification
of sentiment compared to the feed farm,
even though you don't,
please don't look at this much improvement in the
performance, but just to say that it is, uh,
indeed a sequence knowledge is important.
Next slide. Uh,
maybe it's really pla possible we should show on the
sentiment classification IMDV database itself.
Okay? I think this basic assumptions
that I explained in the, uh, already in the explanation,
next position, next slide.
Uh, this one, yeah,
I think this also I explained next.
This is some mathematical equation to say how, uh,
it is, uh, computed.
Uh, I don't have to worry too much about that.
Next, yeah,
next, next slide.
Uh, this vanishing gradient problem.
Uh, this also I explained, uh, next slide.
Uh, I think up to this point,
the short term versus long term will go to lstm.
So the previous, I think with that, I'm stopping here.
If you have any questions, Sunil can continue.
Well, one question you, so apart from sharing the weight,
uh, each of the neuron is sharing input,
is sharing the output also, that way they are able
to remember the sequence of the work.
Ah, can you repeat Rakesh? I,
Uh, yeah. What I'm
saying, apart from sharing the weights,
they are sharing the previous output also.
So yes, that's, uh, where it's remembering the sequence.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Now that is influencing the sequence knowledge,
computation value,
Yeah. Yes, somewhat.
Thank you.
Yeah. Uh, I think Sunni,
do you have some examples to show that?
Yeah, I think you have this. You can proceed.
Thank you.
You are muted your mic, so you're muted your mic.
Oh, sorry, sorry. Yeah.
Um, so I'll just continue from here
and I'll try to, uh, again, emphasize on the same points
what Sarah has told with some examples
and maybe some pictorial representation. Understand,
Just, so, even though it looks slightly repetitive,
this sequence knowledge processing is a very important
aspect of deep learning.
I know. I think, uh, kindly bear with that
double explanation.
Yes. Yes.
Okay.
So I have taken the similar examples what, uh, uh,
uh, took in the last class as well,
that suppose we have a corpus where we have the three
sentences and first sentences of length,
three second sentences of length, five
and third sentence has forward, so of length four.
So what happened when you will build this RN network, uh,
in, in, when you will actually implement that.
So RNN always expect the input
to be in this particular shape.
Okay? Input shape is something like this that
you first say that what is your batch size?
The first number here represent the passage here.
I will be processing each, each sentence separately.
So I'm writing best equal to one, one sentence, uh,
one sentence at a time.
But it is possible that you can group the multiple sentence
together and do the calculation.
So here, but I'll show you one by one maybe.
So that's why the ba batch equal to one.
And the second parameter says that how many words
or what is the sequence length?
So how many times stamp it'll go.
So three essentially says that it'll start from X, no,
it'll go to X one and it'll end at X two.
But in the second sentence, it'll go to start at X.
No, it'll go to X one, the next two, the next three
and X four, right?
And then the third one, it'll go from next node will be deep
X one will be learning.
The next two will be is and x. Uh, three will be powerful.
So this is how at each time stamp, we are going to feed one,
one word, okay?
And the next time stamp will come once we have already done
with the previous time stamp,
it is just like your clock, right?
So the next, uh, next, uh,
next minute will come once this minute has already done.
Next hour will come. This, this,
this time has already, uh, done.
So this is how this RNN will, will work, right?
And this v size, you know,
that I have already told you earlier also,
this V represents, okay,
what are the unique words you have in the entire corpus?
Because, uh, we can't be feeding these words
as it is to the network.
We have to represent them in one vector form.
And this vector, what will the vector length in which each
word here will be represented will be we, right?
So you can see here the representation of each word,
like we, uh, will be this one hot vector.
R will be this, and so on. This is, this is just one.
Uh, as similarly, the other vectors will
also will be represented.
For example, the deep learning, powerful,
everything can be represented,
but here it is shown only for this particular sentence.
We are in LLM class.
And here the stable essentially says
that at the time stamp number, uh,
first we are processing the first word.
Then second, we are processing the second word,
then in then l, l, m, and then class.
So it, it goes, it goes one by one at the time still.
Now, this is for, for a particular example.
Now, in general, what will happen,
the input sequence will be off.
It'll go from x no
to X two in general means XT can be anything.
Uh, it is sometime three to sometime four, five.
So it'll go from X not to xt TT timestamp.
And similarly, the output, uh,
output sequences can be o or not to ot.
But as Sarah also said, that one, these length of X
and O need not to be same.
It'll be different. It, it will, it'll be, for example,
you take the example of the machine translation
where say in English, we have a sentence like, uh,
I am going, right?
Uh, then I am going,
there is three word in this sequence, right?
If I do the, uh, parallel, uh,
translation in Hindi, it'll say me.
So me, it'll be four words in a sentence, right?
So input sequence, length
and output, sequence length, they will not be equal.
Okay? There might be sometimes where there is equal,
but then that is, that is what we don't have to, uh,
consider that it is also going up to t starting with zero.
It is also going up tot h so they are having the same,
same length, right?
So machine translation is a good example.
Whatever language it can be, you know, that one language
to other language length will be different.
Now, what I'll do here is I will just build one neural
network and then show you that how, how this r
and n, uh, pictorially, how it, it is represented,
although sir has explained that,
but just to have a little more insight, understanding
maybe I, I will take this example.
So what I will do, I will take the input dimension as equal
to four, input dimension as equal to four,
and output dimension as equal to three.
Okay? For example, suppose there is any x,
whether it is X node, X one,
or XT for any sentence, every,
every input here will be represented by four dimension,
maybe the four values, where two value will be, uh, uh,
zero, two value heritage,
or two value zero, two value one,
it is a one hot vector representation, or, uh, right?
But then, uh, I, I'll show you that one, how
you can also represent this X node
as an embedded dense vector representation later on.
But here, let us say that this is what is the representation
of XX node, okay?
And, uh, similarly,
because I have fixed your output dimension as you call
to three, then, uh, here the, every output,
every output will be represented by three dimension.
Right Now, neural network architecture, how I want to build,
because I have fixed the number of input dimension equal
to four, at the input layer, you will have four neurons
or four inputs, whatever you say, right?
So four, it is written. Now these four inputs will be
connected with three output layer, just for the simplicity.
I'm not keeping any hidden layer, okay?
Uh, but obviously you can keep the hidden layers also
as as many as you can.
But then here, I'm not keeping any hidden layer.
I'm just keeping one input.
And there is one layer, uh,
and that itself is output layer where I have three neurons.
Why three neurons? Because output
dimension, I have fixed as three.
So I need just three neurons here.
If I output dimension, I'll fix as 10.
That output number of layer neurons will be 10.
That is how it'll be. Now with this setting,
let us now process the time stamp wise, uh, uh,
input, and we'll see that.
How does it look like? Okay?
Just, just, uh, visualization that we are going
to see just everything you know already.
So now, at the time, stamp number T no. Okay?
This is how your network will look like. Okay?
For example, you are feeding the first input that is X.
No, this X is nothing but x sno. You are feeding it.
So X nod is represented by four dimension, okay?
It, it can be a one hot vector representation.
Here I'm showing double one,
but you can just assume that there are,
if it is just one hot vector representation, it may be, uh,
three zeros and one, one.
That's all. Okay?
Three zeros and one, one, maybe I'll put this zero.
Let's just do not get confused further,
because it's just one hot vector representative.
So we have seen that, how to build the one hot vector from,
from the given corpus.
So now see this, this is the, uh,
so every input is represented by one hot vector.
In one hot vector. I have four values.
So four values depends on your vocabulary size.
So I assume that I have only four unique
words in my vocabulary.
Alright? So that's why there is a four. Okay? X.
Well, uh, there are four inputs here.
Now, why we have three, three neurons here.
This is the neurons, okay?
And this is the itself is acting like my output layer.
I am not showing any hidden layer in
between just for the simplicity.
Okay? So these are the three neurons, and, uh, Y three,
because I have assumed that output dimension is three.
So I need to keep three neurons.
Each neuron will give one word output. That's all.
Now, you can treat this, this network
as if Feedforward network, a NN type network,
because every input here is connected
with every other neuron.
You can see that three, sorry, uh, four plus four plus four,
12 connections are there.
Okay? 12 connections are there, right?
So this is, this is nothing but a a NN, right?
It is, it is, uh, it, it has no difference from there.
At least this architecture,
what you're seeing at ts called two zero,
although there is something which I'm not showing you,
that there is one more connection, which is coming from, uh,
which is connected with these neurons at the output layer,
which I'm not showing you, but you can see
that in the equation.
It is written ip.
Suppose ip suppose it is only a NN like the a NN it works.
It would have been x it you plus B.
Because what we do in the a NN at each neuron,
we do the weighted sum plus bias, right?
So weighted sum for this particular neuron would be
whatever input it is receiving that is the, uh, this,
this, this, and this.
Four inputs. And then whatever weights it, it is, uh,
connected with, so X into U, you can just, uh, rep, uh,
understand that.
Uh, X is a collective input representation.
U is a collective output, or sorry, weight representation.
So X into U is the input which is going
to each of these neuron.
Okay? So that's why X dot u dot x node,
you can see that and which is nothing but the a NN.
Now, this is w no, uh, W oh minus one,
which is not visible here.
I'll show you in the next slide.
And that's how you get something at, uh, at this, at each
of these neurons, three different outputs you get,
there's nothing but A and N, right?
But RNN is slightly different,
which I'm going to show you next.
Now, say that at time, time is called to two zero.
This is how my neural network looks like.
And when it comes to time, musical called two one.
Now, when it comes to time is called two one x node.
I have already processed, okay, say that and X one.
I'm trying to process now, okay, X one, I'm trying
to process now see at the x, X is equal to, uh,
one also means time is equal to one also.
And when we are processing X one,
then also my network remains same.
See the connections? I'm, I'm talking about the connections.
Uh, the, here again, you have your number of weights
or you represents all these weights.
How many weights? 12 weights, because you have four inputs
and three outputs, four into three 12 weights.
And every, uh, here, here for, from every neuron,
you are going to get the output that you're getting here.
So doesn't, uh, so, uh, you can see
that the appearance wise, the network wise,
the network which is showing at x, no,
at at t equal two zero.
And at t equal two, one remains same, remains same.
Obviously these inputs will change.
This X one is different from X, not input. Okay?
And accordingly, this output will also change
because input is changing.
What you will get this different set of outputs.
So, uh, this is, this is, again, it looks like a a n, right?
You feed the input, you get the output
feed four one neural network.
So it is also feed four one neural network.
But the only change, which what brings in, in case of this,
uh, RNN, is this one.
Now I am just trying to connect these two
to make you understand it a little better.
So what has happened is this, you can read as X, no,
which we processed already.
Nothing, nothing but this, this particular network, okay?
This is X note means time is stamp physical two zero.
This is what we did. And time is, uh,
timestamp physical two, one.
This is what we are doing. And what happens in the case
of RNN, right?
That they are connected, they are connected by
these weights, they are connected by the, this is
what is the connection,
which is coming from the previous timestamp.
So this is at time stamp is called two zero,
and this is at timestamp, is called two one.
The only difference, you can see
that here we are processing x, no input.
We will have different one hot representation,
x one input will have different
or, uh, input representation goes to the same network.
The only difference is now you can see that each input,
sorry, each neuron here at the output layer
also receives the connections from the last hidden
last la last time stamp hidden layer.
So hidden layer or output layer here in,
in this particular case,
because here, there is no hidden layer.
So the output layer itself is acting as a hidden layer.
So whatever output you get here, it is connected
with all the three neurons in this next time stamp
or put layer neurons.
So you see that three connections goes from this,
three connections goes from this,
and three connections goes from this.
Right? Now, this is what is unique in RNN,
which is not there in the a n
otherwise, if you don't do this, then what is happening,
you know, it is something like this, that X node,
you process one, then, then you process the next word,
then you process the next word.
And that is what happens in the case of a NN, right?
But in the RNN, this is the change what we do.
So these are the set of weight.
Um, this is how the two timestamp, uh,
when you have the same network, they are connected
with this, this, uh, this connection.
The, and this, this is nothing.
But again, the set of weights,
which is represented here by w.
So now you will understand this equation very well.
In the first slide when I showed this equation
was a little confusing, but now you can understand that each
haal layer, or in this case it is an output layer,
receives two inputs.
You can just see here it receives the input from the current
estate, which is X one.
So X one, N two U, it receives here,
it also receives the input from the last hidden estate,
which is this O no, oh, no,
into W And that is what it is written here.
Okay? This is, oh, so this should be or not, okay?
Because we are calculating O one.
This should be or not fine.
Uh, but I guess you're getting this.
Yes, sir. Got it, sir? So I have one quick question. Yeah.
So this recurrence, uh,
previously it was mentioned it would be
for the hidden layer, right?
And not for the output layer.
So why is it for the output layer now?
So I, I don't have any, uh,
I I'm treating this itself as a hidden layer.
You can see that whatever it goes
after this, that's the self.
I, so after this layer, there is
that itself is my output layer.
So there is no hidden layer.
I have assumed that one assume no here
and layer, okay, that's just an assumption.
But you can always have one more layer in between
through which you can show this,
uh, connection. Yeah,
Okay, sir. Got it. So,
But here what I'm doing is this itself is my output layer,
and there this connections is going,
Okay, So, and one more thing, sir.
Like in the previous slide, we had that arrow coming,
it was a single arrow.
Mm-hmm. Uh, now here we are saying
that this feedback from the first neuron, uh, vertical goes
through every, every, ah,
Okay, so it, it a little, uh,
but that's why I said you will go
inside a little bit more insight into the network.
That single arrow when it was coming,
that also represented the same meaning here.
Because usually what happen when you do this, the, uh,
the figure becomes more complex to draw, so
to understand also.
So usually we represent it by single arrow,
but this is the actual case.
What you're seeing here, every output in the previous time
of time are connected with
all the neurons in the current
timestamp in the head and earth.
That is what is happening
In the, so it's quite like that transformer model also,
Uh, transformer that,
Uh, attention
or something is to be, uh, anyway,
leave that sir. I'll, I'll
Let us, let us not bring that yes,
as doesn't have this, this connection.
We'll see that one uhhuh, okay?
As funnel has removed this lstm or RNN sort of connection.
Yeah, yeah, we'll see. Yeah,
Sure. Uh, one more
question. So you said, uh,
the input sequence length
and output sequence would be different, right?
Uh, did you, uh, uh, so in this case,
if we have X zero input, uh, it has its output
and X one has its correspond output.
Uh, so similarly for every other input you on a
positive have its output, right?
So it's always one input and one output.
How, where, where do we depict that, you know,
the input length different from, in my opinion, maybe X zero
to extend is one sequence
and output could be, you know, Y zero to Y five only.
So that was my assumption,
but looks like here, uh, every input has its output.
Uh, here it is like every input has has its own output.
But we'll see that when we go for the, uh,
machine translation case where it is, uh,
where you can understand that that, uh,
the input sequence length is different from
the output sequence length.
We'll see that there is some more, uh, some more, uh,
like, uh, modules come into the picture, okay?
Usually in the machine translation case, what happened,
I will tell you, okay, that, uh,
transformer also you have seen that
you must have observed it.
There is encoder, there is a decoder. Okay? Yeah, yeah.
So, which I'm not showing at least with this, this,
I just trying to relate it to previous side.
We can go back. Um, uh, yeah, one more sir.
One more, one more. Sorry. Yeah. Here, right?
So we thought that X zero
and O zero, uh, the dimension is different, right?
So I was relating to this dimension actually,
it's just one part dimension difference.
It is not real sequence, uh, difference.
This is, this is just a dimension difference.
This is not, uh, related to the sequence directly here,
Right? Okay, got it.
Okay, thank, good.
This is the sequence of what I was talking.
X can have a sequence going from X not to xt.
O can have a sequence going from O, not T.
So each X is represented by these four dimension,
or each O is represented by this three dimension.
This will be fixed, but then this sequence might vary.
It may not go up to T
or O may not go up to T means, uh, it'll go up to T,
but then it'll be less lesser than what X.
That is what I was talking about. Yeah. Okay.
So I guess you understood that. Yeah.
I have one confusion actually.
So sir, for the X one, like it has to be
of the same length of input as the xo.
Yeah, like in this case,
That has to be same. That
has to be same. Okay?
It's, uh, because I told you right, it's nothing
but a NN if you remove this connection red part,
and we have already talked in the case of a NN,
what was happening is that you can't change the input,
uh, how many inputs you want to feed to the neural network.
And that is true for any case.
But only change, which we are bringing is now in the r
and n, we process as many word we have in a sentence,
in a timestamp manner.
And the timestamp manner is possible with this connection
because now we are connecting with same network.
This is this, these two are the same network, right?
This, there is no difference.
Only this makes the difference
and this makes the difference when I say it can only come
with a time stamp, because
unless you don't have these outputs available,
you can't feed it as an input for the next outputs.
As you can see, these connections are going,
so these o nodes should be available to get it connected
with these O one neurons.
So this can only happen with the timestamp, right?
Uh, unless you don't have this, you can't have this.
So that's why I say it goes in the timestamp manner,
but these has to be same.
I mean x, because X is representation, X is a word,
word you can't feed, and what you're representing
with some vector, this vector length, you can't change.
It has to be same for that RNA. Yeah.
So sir, what about different, uh, word length
or like for different sentences?
So, so that's what
I said, that's what I said.
Suppose you have three words in a sentence.
So it'll go from X node, X one, X two,
but X one X node representation
will still be in the four dimension.
It's a representation of X nod or X one or X two.
Suppose you have 10 words in a sentence.
So it'll go from XO to x, extend in that way.
You are, you are, uh,
addressing the variable length sequence problem,
but every input itself will be represented by the same, uh,
same vector length.
Whatever you have planned for this particular network.
Are you getting this point?
These two are two different things.
First of all, then in sentence,
you may have the different words.
Uh, like a sentence can have three words.
A sentence can have 10 words.
How we are addressing that problem by going
with a time stamp manner.
I'm not process. So first,
first time I'm only processing the first word,
then second timestamp, second word.
Obviously there is a connection coming from.
And the third time stem, third word,
likewise, I can go up to 10 also sometime up
to three also sometime at 200 also.
Okay? But in that way it is different in that way.
Variable lens sequence we are addressing.
But what I'm saying is at every time a stem,
every x is a word, right?
You have to represent that word in a vector.
Vector length doesn't change.
Vector is still four here,
four here in the next time stamp also, also, it'll be four
for whatever word we will feed, okay?
Vector length doesn't change.
Time stamp changes for the different sequence length.
Got it, sir? Thank you. Thank
one more question, sir? Yes, yes,
Please, please.
Yes, sir. Sir. Uh, previously we discussed that, uh,
the X will have multiple variance in the first
level, multiple variance
In the sense, Uh, I mean be below U we have x, X zero,
X one, X two, X three, correct?
But now we have, uh, x, x, x one in the,
uh, vertical weight.
So that is kind of confusing, sir.
Oh, it's, it's just, just for representative
because I had to connect these three, uh, outputs
with these weights to these outputs here, right?
Neuron, that's why I have taken it little up.
Otherwise, I, if I would've taken here these many
connection, I would've not shown nucle.
This just a visualization.
It doesn't go vertical way
or so it just a visualization
to connect these mini weights here.
Okay, sir? Thanks, Uh, sir.
In case, uh, in this, uh, diagram,
if we have a hidden layer,
even though then the hidden layer weights will also get
shared to the X one network message.
Yeah, that, that is what, uh, so this treat, this is
as a hidden layer itself and whatever, okay?
Yeah. This is as a hidden layer itself. It is, yeah.
Okay. Now what happened?
This is a time stamp number one,
and it goes on, say that now I have timestamp number two,
that there also it goes on.
So now what, what is current
input? Yes, sir. So it
Is 10 30, I don't know whether they have a class. Yes,
Something, uh, even I have, uh,
so I'll just wrap up within five minutes,
Okay?
Yes.
So, uh, this is what happened.
Uh, see even at the timestamp number two, you can see that
what happened, no, it's not.
We processed, and those connections from OO are connected
with O one neurons here.
So O one receives two input as an X one and as an od.
So for every hidden layer neurons,
they're receiving two inputs.
You see that two input is the same two set of inputs.
One set is coming from the current input,
current word X one.
Another set is coming from last hidden layer output,
which is O not that's why X, X, uh, uh,
here you have disconnected with the weights U
and disconnected with the way W
Now at the timestamp number two, the same thing happened.
The X two gets connected with the U, these are the set
of weights U and this, uh, O one is connected with the W
and hence you get the O2.
That's why O2 is a function of two inputs,
X two and O one.
Obviously they are weighted, uh, connections.
So w and u has to be multiplied respectively. Okay?
So this, this, this, this goes like that, okay?
Now why I'm showing you a little vertically
because I had to show these connection.
That is the only reason, right?
So, uh, uh, you can understand now, uh,
how the weights are being shared.
So huge number of weights we have here. How many?
Four into three 12, same 12 weights are being used here.
Same 12 weights are being used here.
If you have here three neurons connected
with three neurons here, three into three,
nine connections you have here.
Here, okay?
So total number of waves, if you will calculate in this kind
of network, it'll be 12 plus nine.
12 plus nine is equal to uh, how much? 21.
Uh, 21. 21.
And there are three biases with these three neurons, okay?
Bias, also shared bias. Our values are also not changing.
So 21 plus 3, 24, okay? 24.
Uh, so that is, that is what is the number
of parameters in this particular network.
That is what it's okay.
Then timestamp three, the same way it goes on, you see
that this is the connection.
This is how the RNN looks like,
and this is the completely unfolded structure
and this is what sir has shown, uh, later,
that this whole unfolded structure can be
shown here like this.
So, but now this is just a one level
of the slice representation where each input X node,
so every neuron receives two input X, the current input
that is X and the last hidden in output, that is O.
Okay? So you can understand this one here.
It, uh, X one is the current input,
and O node is the last hidden in output.
So X gets multiplied with a u and O gets multiplied with W.
But you always have to remember O is not a scaler.
X is not a scaler, U is not a scaler, and w is not a scale.
All are vectors.
So O also has multiple o's like you can see here, three in,
uh, one output here, one output here, one output here.
These three gets connected with these three.
That's why nine connections are required here, right?
So although, uh, just for the representation,
we show single, single neuron,
but actually they are set of values,
not a single values, they're a vector.
Okay? And then further, uh, if you will see the compact view
of the RNN, this is the view you will have where every X
is connected with the neuron with the U weight.
Like you can see X not connected with UX one, connected
with UX two, connected with U.
So here it is showing that particular connection
and every O is connected with itself.
So this loop is nothing where this, the,
here the output gets connected with this output.
Here, here the output gets connected with this output here.
And that's why this loop, it's showing that it is connected
with itself with the next time step in,
the next time step, right?
And that's how you get the final and,
and uh, that's, that's
how you can calculate the final output at each time stamp
and even at the final time step.
Okay? So this is even the compact implementation
or complete compact representation
of the recurrent neur network.
Okay? Rest, I guess sir has explained, maybe I'll stop here.
We have already exceeded the time.
You may also have the class, right?
So if you have any quick question, you can ask.
Otherwise we'll continue with the next class,
Sir. Uh, so in
this type of inter sharing of weights
and connections across the timestamps,
so then it is much more prone
to this vanishing ingredient. No, sir.
Yeah, yeah, that's what I had told. Yes
Sir. That what we
now we can able to able to see
that visually and how this thing,
Yes, yes, yes, yes, correct
Sir. From application
point of view, where can we find RN
and being dominant
Everywhere, wherever you are dealing with text, if you go
to the Gmail and you see that there is a,
next word it is suggesting you RN
and WhatsApp, when you use in the keyboard, you see
that it giving you the next word prediction, rn
and everywhere there is an RNN transformer network has come
now, but transformer networks are difficult
to implement everywhere, right?
Because it's a heavy network,
but the RN that simple as compared to the transformer
and for certain cases it really performs well when the
sequence length is a small, like five words, 10 words.
Okay? It, it works well in such cases,
wherever you see the text data
and it's any kind of intelligence is happening.
That's RNN. Yeah.
Whether anywhere you just see that one. Okay.
Okay. Thanks. One quick question sir.
Uh, so since we have this, uh, recurrent, uh, factory,
we've added to the existing neural network.
Mm-hmm. So similarly do we have a concept
of recurrent adding to the existing CNN network?
Sir, is there anything, something you like that sir,
There that is called our CNN.
Okay. So it is there where people have tried to, uh,
combine these two concept of recurrent with the CNN,
that is called RCN.
Uh, we may not cover that, but you can look into that. Yeah.
Okay. Okay, Sir, on behalf of the class, um,
we had an assignment due tomorrow, graded one.
So somebody had told us that, that you had agreed with him
to change the date to the next week.
So the class is asking sir.
Okay. Okay. We'll do that. We'll do that.
So next week, not tomorrow, sir?
Yeah, yeah, not tomorrow, next week? No, that's fine.
Okay. Next Sunday then. Yeah,
Please. Uh, vial,
are you there?
You can just change the, extend the deadline.
Yes, sir. We we'll do that, sir. Yeah,
Fine. Thank, thank you
Sir. Uh, did you get
to check on the mid, oh,
I have checked that one question.
Anyway, we are, uh, that, that, uh, L two problem, uh,
I have checked that we'll discuss in the next class.
I forgot to discuss today. That is fine.
I guess I will discuss with you one more question.
What was asked, uh, you have told
that we are not considering there is some that
complete information is not given in that question.
That actually this got one question on that, uh,
reduction on the weight parameters when we do implementing
feedforward new network and see an answer.
So that calculation also have shared
with the women today morning, like how we Yes, sir.
So I considered the number of filters
and this, I can see it's coming approximately 9.91%,
which is, uh, you can say approximately 10 times.
Okay? So because CN will not have a minimum reduction,
like 2.7 if you take,
because we are having this pretest. Ah,
That's what I said. That
question is not, uh, that,
that question will not consider.
Yeah, I have seen that question. Yes, yes.
That question will not consider for evaluation. Yes.
Is it, uh, 10 times? No, sir. It not 2.7.
Uh, I not, uh, so that is a confusion. I understand that.
Uh, so it, it is not completely clear.
When you draw the architecture, it is 2.7% or 10%, right?
Yes. It's not clear with that question, sir. Yes,
That question. It depends upon
the number of learn, like
how much is the depth we take
and how much is the size of the filters we see
Size of the filter. It
depends on multiple factor, which is not Yes, sir.
Question, sir. Yeah, I understand that. Correct.
So, so, uh, so based on architecture, it depends, right?
Yes. So the reduction varies?
Yes. Yes. We'll not consider that for evaluation.
Sure, sir. And al two,
al two question we'll discuss in next
Al two question will discuss. That
question is fine. I believe that we'll discuss that.
No, no problem. Okay,
Sir. Thank you sir.
Thank you. Thank you all. Thank you, sir. Sir,
Thank you sir.
Thank you, sir. Thank you, sir.